Okay.
Hey,
what's going on is still burning.
It's time for the Monday
morning podcast for Man da. Um,
April 4th, 2016. How's it going?
How I yeah, I am an Ottawa,
Canada right now. Oh,
can uh,
it's fucking freezing here.
Every time I come,
I know.
Stroll stick together. Um, yeah, we came,
we did fucking almost in Wichita. I
don't know what the fuck the named place.
Windsor.
We did Windsor.
Me Versie and fucking Joey be job partner.
We did a Windsor the first day.
Yeah.
I don't even know what day that is yet.
Friday we did it on Friday and um,
I bought this little fucking bitchy coat.
Nia calls it the Kleenex code.
It's just to Celine,
all those little ones in the 70s.
And when they had the big puffy coats,
well,
they're still making the puffy coats to
not just like, they're like little once,
you know what I mean? They look like
little, uh, you know, like you're,
you're a rib shack and you open a little
thing and then give me a little morsel.
Talent looks like there's a bunch of
those sewn into the code. You know that.
Thank you know what the fuck
coat on talking about? Well,
it was all north north face numbers.
So I got dad on a Hoodie because I looked
at the fucking forecast and it said
that um,
you know,
it's going to be like 50 degrees
and that coach good down to 40.
So I thought I was fine.
I was fine.
I was snug like a little bug in a
rug with first. Was it two days?
What hell was I?
The second day.
Okay.
Oh, the second day I was at
Casino Rama. That's right.
And that's when it started to snow and
that's when I started questioning my,
my jacket game is the young kids
say my jacket game was not on point.
However,
by the way,
I didn't bring any of my fucking podcast
equipment because you know this trip is
a motherfucker. All right. This is one
of these, it's known in my businesses.
A thrash. All right?
Sometimes you go on the road,
it's a fucking cake walk. All
right. Whatever the fuck that means.
What is a cake walk? I know.
I've never even looked that up.
Is there a certain kind of way you
walk when you fucking carrying a cake?
Maybe that's what it is. Sorry if I'm
fucking, the levels are too high year.
Just trying to talk to him. I
recorded like a microphone. Um,
that's going to be my guess.
Yeah.
Is that when you have a fucking cake,
you know?
Yeah.
If you have a KCI going to be be walking
a little gingerly, no offense to me.
Right?
So you walk a little lightly with it.
Maybe you know what you're walking like
you walk in like Paul Versey when he
puts on his fucking Jordan
fours for the first time,
you should have seen him
walking down the casino.
He was walking like on his heels
because he didn't want to create some,
I got to tell you something.
I don't fucking understand.
People who fucking stand in line and then
stab each other over a fucking pair of
sneakers. I just really, dude, did
you see they got the new Jordans?
Three zero dude,
that fucking crazy.
The new Jordan threes are fucking crazy.
I swear to God,
they all look like nurse shoes to make
big, stupid, bulky looking fucking things.
I think I have a pair of Jordan ones.
I liked the colors.
I never liked those fucking things.
Either one,
they came out and they were red and black.
I thought those were the ugliest
fucking thing. So I told you before,
I'm farther back in the day.
I liked those Bruce Jenner.
Um, the capital on shoes, you know,
just simple pair with fucking
three stripes on the side.
I was cool with sneakers,
right through towards the end of the
eighties when they started having like the
fucking Bo Jackson,
the Neon,
Deon fucking remember that
neon green and Neon pink.
Those fucking sunglasses to
second and went into that shit.
Those pastel colors and the
stupid fucking Reebok pump. Oh,
maybe if I put some more air in my
sneakers, I won't have white guy legs.
The Reebok pumps where we're as stupid
is Batman versus Superman there.
Alright. Okay Shirley.
Here we go. This cake walk.
Surely you've heard the term cakewalk.
Did somebody write a whole fucking
article on this? Good Lord.
Cut to the fucking chase. All right.
I'll read this as fast as I can.
Surely you've heard the term cakewalk
used to describe some sort of challenge or
tasks that is reckoned
to be pitifully easy.
Surely you have what you stop saying
that? Stop calling me. Surely.
Surely you have. Please.
Please don't lie. Good Lord.
Who fucking wrote this?
MMM.
The figurative definition has been
around since the early 19th century.
As long as the literal one,
in fact it appeared in print,
but did you know that the term is
actually pretty racist, racist, racist,
racist?
I'll bet you didn't.
What the fuck is wrong with this idiot
who this is such a classic, you know,
if you actually had to get a real job
writing, you wouldn't have one. You know,
everybody on the Internet fancies
themselves like there's some sort of
journalist, you know when
they're writing, this is just no,
you just fucking write in on a w.
Okay.
It's like acting in a web series
and you're upset. You didn't get nominated
for a fucking Oscar. Uh, nor did I. Okay.
Did you know it was pretty
racist? Um, I'll bet you didn't.
Okay.
What?
Because you don't know some shit and
that means everybody else does it and you
fucking cunt. I mean, I didn't
know it, but I'm a moron.
I really don't like this person.
Uh, he said nor did I. Okay.
That's the first humble thing this
person said, maybe you can come around.
Maybe I was wrong.
I still don't think I could drive
cross country with this person. Um,
nor did I until I looked into the origin
of the term and found out it had roots
in the,
okay.
I don't know how to say
this word. Antebellum south
of the early 19th century.
Can you just tell me
what the fuck it means?
I would started during this era of
firmly entrenched slavery in the states.
The cakewalk was a dance event
where slaves were invited
to dress up in the fine
clothes and took on the heirs
of the white aristocracy.
Oh, so this is like when the
Wayans brothers did white chicks.
What do they do? It? Is this
like the first def jam comedy?
They started doing the white gay voice.
I said,
get out in the field to do the
work that I should be doing.
And everybody starts flipping
out, dying, laughing.
The next slave coming to
the stage. Um, all right.
They were held in the plantation home in
the same rooms where the risk splendid
balls were held among white society.
Oh my God.
How much did those people
fucking stink back then?
Putting on all those extra
layers of clothes? No such
thing as deodorant. Right.
Just join you as one of those things
where you're washed yourself in the same
fucking trough. The God damn
horses drank out of, uh,
the cakewalk was similar. It was
a ball held for the slaves. Oh,
so this is a Christmas party.
I didn't know they did that.
Okay.
I didn't see that. And roots,
you know, it wasn't all bad.
Every once in a while they had look a
company party after 364 and a half days of
absolute horror than they would.
They let him in the house. Yeah. Hey,
sorry about all that other shit.
Would you like some pumpernickel
the wife just made it. Oh,
let's get him out of the house side.
They seem to be a little restless.
That's fucking nuts. Oh, what
an ugly period. The cake like,
you know, like [inaudible] parried
but you know Celeste ugly. All right,
let's continue. Okay. The
cake walk was similar.
It was a bald ball held for the slaves.
Couples promoted promenaded sorry.
Through the ballroom,
bowing deeply and frequently.
Chins and noses held highly aloft.
If you're going to tell me,
they finally gave him a fucking party
and they still were assholes about it.
The couple who performed
the best interpretation of
how the white folks did it.
One a cake baked one imagines by a slave.
I didn't imagine that stuff
put words in my mouth.
I would figure the white people after
all the fucking time. But yeah. Well,
you know what? Uh, I consider
we ruined their fucking lives.
I think we can make
them a cake once a year,
but we're only given it to one of them.
Jesus Christ.
Every time you think you've found the
depths of how evil that shit was, he,
you find another layer. Oh my God.
Another layer. Just like a cake.
Jesus. I'm an artist this morning. All
right. The cake walk looks similar,
but it was also very different.
It's intent was to emulate white
society in order to market or the Jesus,
there's a dangerous fucking gave me,
I told you this is like the first def
jam comedy and much the same way as
oh Jesus Christ.
Saturnalia the ancient Rome
winter solstice festival.
Oh yeah. Exactly. Watching
the same fucking way, um,
where the rules of social order were
turned upside down in the slaves and
laborers became the rulers
and Matt and masters attended
attend their servants.
Oh they did this in Rome.
This is just all fucking weird.
Can you imagine the tension during that?
So then the master's fucking
okay.
Tended to the slaves and you know, the
slaves wanted to be just as fucking me,
but then they were like,
well we got to kind of alligator arm this
shit cause it goes back to the regular
way tomorrow. And then I would
think the master be like, all right,
you want me to wade into that
sea of hatred towards me?
Um, uh, just keep an eye on
me. Please stay tight. Okay.
It's still the left side of my nose. That
means a, I'm fearing for my life. Uh,
the slaves involved did indeed mark
the ridiculously refined customs of the
aristocracy. Yes. And they surely
meant it, but during the cakewalk
they were allowed to mock them.
And by ruling over even the very event
that should undermine his authority,
the plantation owners, managers to
assert his authority. You know something?
I was in such a fucking good mood.
I hate this shit.
Okay?
It's a fucking cakewalk. Well, you
know what? I already clicked off.
So how does that mean?
It's easy.
What does that mean?
It's, it's a cheap laugh
and know I got to go back. I just closed
the fucking window. I got to go back.
So how the fuck did that?
Because that does not sound easy to me.
Being a slave all year and then doing one.
Did you get to do one fucking day?
We get to make fun of this.
The master.
It's not a cakewalk and struck
a difficult, right? Yeah.
Yeah.
All right.
As if its roots in slavery don't make
the cakewalk racially charged enough.
It transitioned in the menstrual show.
How did it transition into
making something easy of
the Jim Crow era or even,
or even worse?
Um,
okay.
Gone was even the power.
A lot of to the slaves.
Yeah.
By the mark and just have the original
cakewalk and stage reproductions of balls
of the balls.
White performers in blackface performed
as blacks who made sincere clumsy
attempts at emulating whites
out of a desire to be like them,
not to undermine them. Ah,
okay. And then it became that.
I still don't understand why it's easy.
The original cakewalk.
Okay.
Walks being local affairs. How the, you
know what? Fuck the fucking Internet.
All right.
Can I fast forward to this?
Okay.
Oh God, he use the word
apparently. There's no other word.
Alternative comics like to use more
than that apparently. All right.
Clumsy attempt.
So I thought the original cake walks
were being local affairs held in the
confines of the set southern plantation,
the minstrel shows traveling
as a matter of course,
it was later interpretation and it became
defined the concept of the rest of the
country in the world and
what the kids describe.
Perhaps it's a deep desire to stop being
so incredibly racist American society
as a whole.
The banner,
the racial basis of the cakewalk in favor
of it's simply describing something so
easy that just walking could
yield the reward of a cake.
There it is.
The definition is still vaguely racist.
Okay.
It isn't racist if you think that
definition means it's going to be easy.
You're not even being remotely vaguely
racist. You just don't know the history,
right?
Yeah. Jesus Christ. All right, well
there's that was fucking depressing. Um,
well fortunately I'm up here
in Canada where, you know,
they have all the angelic white people
according to Michael Morris, you know,
up here they're all a bunch of angels
and nobody has to lock their doors. Uh,
which of course we know that's true.
Just generally speaking,
people don't get along with
one another. Um, all right,
so that was an excruciating 15 minutes.
I don't know how you guys enjoyed it.
So anyways,
kind of fuck did I get onto that shit?
Oh, because yeah, I thought the whole, um,
okay.
I thought the, I thought this whole
trip was going to be a muffin dance.
How about that?
Can I say something like that?
That was going to be
a little muffin dance.
Did you know that the
origins of Buffett Dance,
um, you actually, our
pro domestic violence.
I bet she didn't.
Surely you've heard the term muffin
dance before. Please, please,
please don't tell me you have not.
Okay.
The origin of Muffin dance
comes from the early 19 hundreds
when women, when they
asked, can we vote to,
were forced to show their clams and
dance out of the voting booths as people
through desserts at the,
uh,
this became known as the muffin dance
because clamp indicated that their pussy
stunk and turn men off.
Later in 1929,
the great,
great grandson of Abraham Lincoln said,
I cannot tell a lie.
Some of these bitches clamps to stink,
but there's still reason to
make them do a muffin. Dads,
they should be allowed to vote too. And
all the guys said, yeah, you know what?
You're right.
And everybody had muffins.
So next time you used
the term buffer dance,
just know that you're
being vaguely sexist. Um,
all right, I'm sorry. Why am I doing
this? Why am I talking like this?
Why of why am I sitting here in this
fucking freezing cold hotel room?
I can't find where the fucking heat
is. I'm saying in one of these. Um,
and I'm a red rum.
Um,
okay.
Well just one of those, you know, I like
old shit to a point, you know, I like,
I thought I liked had having an old house
until I fucking had to deal with it.
Okay.
Oh, all the bullshit of how on an old
house, old hotels, I kind of like,
I loved the lobbies, but the second
you fucking go up to your room,
you start walking down the hall.
You know,
you feel like you should be riding a big
wheel and you're going to come around
the corner, and those too creepy fucking
chicks are going to be standing there.
God dammit, that fucking movie
freaked me out. That movie still got,
it's still disturbing. That's just a
disturbing fucking movie, you know?
And it's not the fact that he
goes completely fucking insane.
It's just as a comedian watching a man
suffering through writer's block like
that, and having that woman
coming up who's face is
shaped like a fucking parking
meter, asking you how it's
going every fucking 20 minutes.
I love how they blame the
fucking hotel rather than that,
you know?
Yeah.
Why did I, would you say
she means well? Yeah,
they just were a bad couple.
I think that that's what it was.
And when they went down in society,
they could go to events and
they could sort of watered down.
They're awful relationship
by interacting with others.
And then once they just got,
you know,
let's say we'll just stay in there
at the fucking hotel, you know,
for the whole God damn winter.
I don't understand why they had to be
there to watch it. You know what I mean?
Like what do you, what are you going to be
doing up there? I mean, it's, it's some,
it's the level with which said, it's
going to fucking snow. No asshole.
He's going to go up there and vandalize
the place. If they come there,
it's cause they need shelter.
It was really no reason
for it,
you know?
And that was also a vaguely racist movie,
wasn't it?
You know,
seeing that reverse racist, that
white people will be like, oh yeah.
Oh the fucking snow's 50 feet
in the fucking air. Oh yeah,
I got to write a book. Yeah. Why
don't I fuck it? Go up there.
Y'All hang out there and I'll, I'll do
my own room service every fucking day.
I'll stay in room fucking
706 and every day I'll take a fucking
elevator all the way downstairs to the
kitchen.
How,
who the fuck would sign up for that free,
didn't have any sympathy for,
you know, I'm just fucking with
you. I think it's a great movie.
I'm just in a grumpy,
goddamn moved considering I going
to drive from fucking Ottawa.
Are we up to Sudbury?
And then right after the show I
got to do my travels all fucked up.
I got to drive over to fuck Detroit,
which is like a fucking eight hour drive.
You know,
it takes me back to the days when I was
doing college gigs and I remember one
time I had this gig and the upper
peninsula of Michigan, right?
Some fucking town up there that
began with an h. All right,
so like an asshole. I'm like, alright,
I'm in Michigan and I didn't
look on the map to see where,
uh, to see where, you know,
basically the fucking
college was at and I just,
I just flew right into fucking Detroit
and then I realized that the upper
peninsula as actually it's sort of,
you know,
it's the Dick of Wisconsin.
I should have flown into
fucking Milwaukee and driven up,
but I didn't,
I flew into Detroit and I had to go
drive all the way up the whole fucking
state. It was pretty cool cause
I got to drive over there.
Whatever bridge that is, the Mackinaw
bridge and whatever the fuck it is.
I'm trying to look it up right now, but
I can't remember the name of the fucking,
I think it was Marquette. Oh, he
started begin with an age maybe.
I was thinking Lake Huron.
I think it was in Marquette.
I did a fucking gig up there.
Yeah. And I had like a,
I forget what time my flight was,
but I had to basically,
it was an early morning flight in Detroit.
It was like a fucking eight hour
drive or some shit, seven hour drive.
And the show didn't start till nine I
was done at 10 o'clock and had like a six
or 7:00 AM flight. I can't remember. And
I just, I was just like, you know, ah,
goodnight everybody.
And I jumped in my fucking car and just
drove like a fucking lunatic after her.
Are you having done the drive?
Drove all the way back.
Just like nodding off.
Almost fallen asleep as one of
the dumbest things I ever did.
Just trying to save like the fucking
$50 change fee or some shit like that.
So you would think that
I would learn from that.
Okay.
Not Old freckles,
but this time we actually have a,
I got like Barnett confers you to
help me with the fucking drive.
Yeah.
Oh my God. Dude. Sudbury is
okay.
Yeah.
It's as high up as fucking
the upper peninsula.
Michigan.
What a fucking ass off for some
reason they're going. Yeah,
there's never really know
airports around here.
I don't know why we didn't just
take a couple of puddle jumper,
so I have no fucking, oh,
I know why. I know why.
Initially I was picking up a rental car
in Detroit and I was going to drive this
whole thing and then at the last
second they're like, you know,
it's a pretty long fucking
drive. So I said, hi.
Well we'll fly most of it and
then we'll do the thing, you know?
Then we'll get the rental car,
we get the rental car and fucking Ottawa,
blah blah blah. We'll do it one way. But
then I was still leaving out of Detroit.
This is so fucking stupid.
Oh, this is gonna suck.
But anyways, what will be
cool tonight I'm playing a uh,
a small, like a hockey arena
and a, I was going to be great.
Ask him to be fucking good time.
I did.
I played one of those last night
here in Ottawa, Ell, civic center,
whatever the fuck it was called.
Uh,
anyways, this is, and what
the fuck I want to talk about.
I need something else I want,
I want to talk about,
but I got to read the
fucking advertising here.
I know this podcast is all over the place.
Okay.
I can't say it's a
fucking cake walk anymore.
Can't say the cake walk anymore
because now I know it's fucking racist.
All right, well actually I go,
I can't say it to you guys,
but I could say it somewhere else.
You know who's kidding who I'm going to
say I'm going to say it cause I've been
saying it my whole fucking life. You
know, it's just going to cut and that's,
that's how you book.
That's how you become an old person.
Or someone's going like grandpa.
Yeah.
Do you know the origin of that? Oh,
shut up your first year. Freshmen.
All right. You fucking concept. Been
around 80 years. Stop breaking my balls.
If I want to say 23 scooter, God
damn it. I'm going to say it.
If you know it was cute,
you almost kill your fucking grandfather
trying to get them to stop saying
something. All right, let me, let
me get to the uh, advertising here.
Oh, here we go. Oh, the old trunk
club. Trunk Club. Everybody.
Do you hate going to the
mall? Sure. We all do.
You surely you've been to a mall.
Surely you're not going to sit
there and say you haven't. Um,
trunk club shopping takes forever
and no one has time for it. Well,
people will enjoy it too. They
live for it. Let's go shopping.
It'll is fucking dope.
It just go down and they will sit
there and look at outfits. You know,
never once putting their ear up to the
shirt and hearing the crying child that's
sewed it together.
You know,
throwing out their old fucking clothes
just end up in the ocean or in some
hipsters back who pretends he
had the job you had. Right. Um,
shopping, you know, I just always drop
off clothes at goodwill. Who's kidding?
Who I still do. And I thought it went to
fucking homeless people and it doesn't,
it just goes right on their racks and
they turned around and they sell them,
which makes me feel good knowing that
they don't end up in a goddamn ocean.
Right. I ways. And now it's spring.
So you need pastel polos and boat shoes.
Right.
And it'd be nice to have your
own personal stylist too.
I think that it has to be a joke.
Nobody needs pastel polos and boat shoes.
I think that those should only be
for the upper 1% of this country.
You know what I mean?
It's for the robber barons and their
date rape his children, you know,
and they can walk around and won't be
great as you make an exclusive for them.
So they'll feel like, oh, look
at us. We are a cut above.
It will be like a status symbol.
But really what it is is it's a warning
for anyone that dates their children.
You know what I mean? It was set out and
wearing the scarlet a, the euro whore,
you just have those pastel colors.
Just be like, you know, it gives,
it gives the ladies a little heads up.
You know that there's going to be a
sense of entitlement coming at him with a
heart on, right? You got to give them
the fucking heads up. Jesus Christ.
Just trying to do my part here,
right?
Let me pour out a little wine
cooler for Edith Wharton here. Um,
and it'd be nice to have your own
personal style is too with trunk club.
You don't ever have to set a foot in a
store and you get your very own stylist
for free. Make it easy to look your
best and clothes that fit you perfectly.
Can't take by your own personal
stylist for free with Trunk Club.
Go to trunk club.com/burr
type in your measurements,
share your likes and dislikes and you
get your very own personal stylist.
A, they'll pick your clothes
from Okinawa. My God,
this is a muffin dance right here.
They'll pick your clothes from over 80
top brands and ship them right to you.
Do A, you keep what you like. Can you
send back what you don't in the trunk?
A trunk club.
You know what they're going to fucking
send these close to some maniac. Okay.
Some serial killer.
Cause you know they don't like to go
to malls either unlisted trolling for
victims.
Right.
And what's going to happen is they're
going to get confused and they're going to
go, you know, you know,
which is the fucking the uh,
I don't like this shirt
trunk in which is the one,
this stuff in the body and they're going
to fucking throw a bunch of shirts in
the bottom of a lake and they're going
to send her body back to trunk club.
I'm calling that right now.
Calling that right now.
Then they're going to do a first 48
about it. But when this trunk showed up,
they couldn't understand why they shirt
smelled so bad. I'm sorry. It's bad.
Trunk Club is not just another
way to shop online. It isn't.
Your style is takes the
time to your unique, your
unique look if you live in.
Okay.
It's just so funny about it.
I was just picturing somebody standing
in a mirror looking at themselves,
trying to figure out, they look, you know,
you know that little thing where you
have your hands on your hip and then you
stick one foot in front of the other.
Like you're a horse answering a
question because she want some oats. Um,
and if you live in Dallas, Do York,
Los Angeles, Chicago, a, d c, uh,
you can stop by one of the trunk
club club houses to work with you.
Stylists in person for free.
Now wait a minute.
I thought the whole point was
not to go to a fucking store.
Trunk Club is not a subscription service.
There's no monthly fee.
This is what I like here.
You stylist is free.
Shipping is always free and you have
10 days to try to try on the clothes.
Risk free. What are you putting
it off? Like a term paper. Oh God,
I gotta try that shirt on.
Make a statement at the next big events
on your calendar with the looks that's
handpicked just for you and your style.
Mike, what are you trying to say?
I'm trying to stay on the TEI
rapists with white pastel colors.
Get started at Trunk Club today.
Premium close expert advice.
No work. Thanks to your very own
personal stylist at trunk club.
Get started today@trunkclub.com slash bar.
That's trunk club.com/bar excuse me.
Trunk club.com/bar.
Sorry my voice is a lot of out of it.
I've been screaming my jokes for
three nights in a row. Oh God.
Am I really going to start a
sing right now? Oh fuck. Okay.
Bodo to dupe me undies.
Me undies.
No more sweaty balls. Boo. Doo
Doo, Doo me undies me undies.
Skating down the fucking
canals here in fucking Ottawa.
You're on the canal.
You're wearing your Randy's with your pal.
Both your balls are really
fucking dry. In fact, again,
getting really chafed cause it's cold.
You me undies. We'll keep him warm.
Alright me undies. By the way, if
you ever skate the canal out here,
I've always been afraid to do
it. You know, I, I've done it,
but I was nervous when I did it.
I just kept thinking about the omen
like I was going to fall through and
everyone's going to be hacking at
the ice trying to get me out again.
The canals only a foot deep, you
know, it's really no big deal.
So worst thing that could happen
is you could get severe frostbite,
may have to remove both your
feet like in that movie misery.
Um, well in the movie she just fucking
breaks his ankles and the book,
she cuts off his fucking feet.
I love when they do shit
like that and it's just like,
okay so you've severed a major artery
and this guy somehow doesn't bleed out in
the bed.
Cause let me guess,
you tied your fucking
belt around his calf.
Does that even work by the way?
If somebody fucking did you see the
fucking redneck that blew his God damn leg
off?
Oh my God,
this is new fucking thing that
rednecks are doing. You know,
cause they just love shooting
stuff and blowing stuff up.
And as much as people you know,
who don't have their own spread
living in the middle of nowhere,
judge them somewhere in the back
of your head, you know, it's fun,
you know,
riding around on a fucking four wheelers,
shooting a gun on your own
fucking property. You know,
it's got to feel great. That's a level
of freedom that I, I've never heard,
I've never felt, you know, I live in
the city where there's noise ordinances,
you know, which basically noise on
my property should not carry over.
Like you can basically call the cops if
somebody splashed around that pool too
loud.
He's mocked the fact I don't have one.
Um, the cops go over, then he just
started beating people, right?
Or air quote, getting the
situation under control. Um,
Christ, what the fuck was I just talking
about? Oh yeah. Riding around, you know,
so I watched this,
this new thing that they do.
They take this some sort of explosives
and they put it in these old cars and
then hopefully they stand far enough
away and the fucking thing blows up.
Well, this fucking guy, alright,
redneck blows.
Look at this shit right here it goes.
Redneck blows himself up,
blows up house,
blows himself up in a bonfire,
blows up pigs almost blows his head off.
This is such redneck stuff.
Stupid redneck blows himself up.
A fire blows up,
blows himself up.
Boat Motor blows up.
Fucking rednecks and crazy blows leg off.
Okay,
let's see. Where is it?
Come on. All right. Yup.
And an American gun enthusiast. A.
Yeah, that's an all American in there.
American Georgia man loses leg f
for explosives filled lawnmower.
Um, I will link you that she
don't see his leg blown off,
but you blow blow off his body.
But this guy,
basically, it's called, uh, I
hope I say it right Tanner. Right?
It's some sort of explosive and the new
thing that these rednecks too is they
fucking
okay.
He fucking, uh, you know,
you put it in whatever
vehicle in order to is,
it's really what's going on here with
these rednecks are starting to be a little
more classy, you know, after
all these fucking years of, uh,
you know, having a card die, they
just leave it on their front lawn.
Now they're getting rid of it. They're
blowing them up. So they put this Tanner,
right?
Whoever the fuck he saying this is
explosive and there's some sort of formula
like basically for every
such and such amount,
you need to be like a hundred feet
back. All right? So let's say whatever.
What we'll just say this guys, if he,
he's got a handful of this fucking Tanner.
Oh God. We're doing math now,
Bill. Alright. And he needed,
he basically needed to be about like,
I don't know,
500 feet back and he was 40
feet away from this lawn mower.
Any fucking shoots the shit.
Right?
He fucking shoots ish.
And uh,
he blows the fucking thing up.
All right.
Listen to this shit.
Yeah. Somebody had to do
their fucking Dj remix of it.
Anyways, he's shooting and
he's shooting a lot more shit.
All of a sudden it fucking blows up and
then he's on the ground and you see it.
You just, you can't see anything. You just
at the camera's pointing at the ground,
he just hear him go, I blew my leg. Oh,
fucking unbelievable. I'm amazed
that he could actually say that.
I would just be staring at
the stop going. Ah. I mean,
well he's got to tell that story
for recipe. At what point does that,
can he laugh along with everybody else?
You know?
I bet he's considered like
a tragic, tragic figure now
and the redneck community,
you know, like he'll probably, you know,
at the next cross burning,
they let him light it.
He hobbles up and everybody
gives him a round of applause.
Like they're all fucking sad.
Like what happened to them with some
sort of a terrorist act rather than self
imposed fucking stupidity.
Jesus Christ, you know,
I feel bad for the guy,
but
okay,
the fuck are you doing shooting a
God damn gun at dynamite basically,
whatever the fuck it is
in a God damn lawn mower.
That's the fucking blade alone.
The shrapnel from that,
I gotta look this shit up.
Top 10
dumb ways to blow you out to
die. All right, let's see.
We'll go with that today. All right. What?
You don't want to hear your
march madness brackets,
top 10 dumb ways to die.
Uh,
there's always the opening the elevator
doors before the elevator gets there and
not looking and then stepping
in and falling to your death.
Yeah,
playing with guns.
I don't fucking know I or top 10
dumbest ways to die. Here we go.
All right.
Starving in a supermarket.
I don't even want to read that one.
Diving off a cliff,
but survive but die of shock from the
high price of your hospital bill. Oh,
Jesus Christ.
Oh Jesus.
I don't need to hacky jokes.
I have plenty of those. C'Mon.
10 absolute dumbest. Wasted. Die.
All right,
this is all going to be
clickbait horse shit.
Okay? You know what? Go
Fuck Yourself. He goes,
should be dying right now
waiting for me to read this shit.
Trying to kiss a reflection
of the moon in a lake.
All right? Somebody died doing that
and then I got to click another page.
You know what I mean?
Once he can have advertising on every
fucking page and somehow you can fucking
afford Twinkies this month. Go Fuck
Yourself. All right. So when it was,
just talk about the,
okay,
the Tory or so the first,
the first day we were in Windsor,
right across from Detroit and um,
okay.
It was awesome. Our upstate, this great
hotel and you can look right across the,
uh,
okay.
What are the fucker was, I guess
it isn't Lake Eerie, isn't it?
Okay.
It's just a river.
I don't know what the fuck you call it.
Is it a sound? Oh, the Detroit river.
And you see beautiful downtown Detroit
and Detroit never looks more beautiful
when you're not in Detroit when
you're across the fucking river.
Looking at it from Windsor. And I just
kept asking a bunch of people like,
cause I'm going to invest, I want to buy
something in Detroit, I'm going to do it.
God dammit, you know,
invest back in America.
I think I totally believe in that city.
I know it's going to come back.
And I was asking people where to fucking
invest and they would just all laugh.
And you're like about 40 miles north.
Like nobody believes in it,
which is what's making me want to
fucking buy. They're even more, you know,
it's fucking dirt. God damn cheap.
It's gonna to come back at some point.
It has to come back.
Sit right there on the river.
I know the fucking Cleveland Cavaliers
guy bought up a bunch of fucking
skyscrapers there has got to,
you know,
he put like the people from Google
and one of them I have no idea.
Yeah,
but the shit is so cheap there. I don't,
I don't get how you fucking loose.
And I liked the idea.
You go in there, right?
You've fixed the fucking place up that
you buy and then you don't kick the
people out that live in there.
And then they got a nice place to live.
Right.
Maybe that gets them in a better mood.
Slowly but surely it just start turning
it around. I think any American, right,
what we should deal with
these fucking cities.
Cause God knows the government's
not going to do anything.
I don't think they can because they're
bitches to the fucking Federal Reserve
bankers, right. I don't have any fucking
money. They're robbing Peter to pay Paul.
So I think with whatever money they let
us keep, we ought to just start fucking,
you know, buying up some shit
and Detroit, turn it around.
Don't kick the people
out, get it. Go on and get
okay.
Maybe then they could start
making American cars right. It get
start fucking with the,
the Audis.
And it's a fucking travesty that we
don't really have anything they can fuck
with those cars.
The fact that they're going to allegate
around the base level Cadillac,
the base level, Lincoln
Continental. Alright,
I'm going to pale in comparison to what
those maniacs in Germany are doing.
I mean, I don't understand why you
don't, you know, we could fucking do it.
I guess Buicks are selling like fucking
hotcakes. Is it? Is that a racist,
a racist thing. And then we'd kinks in
it, I think is racist. Hotcakes. Uh,
back in the day when they
were actually every 10 years,
let us slave have a birthday.
One of the things the slave owners would
do was actually heat up the cake so we
would burn it, burn their mouths
because they were that evil.
Here's another chapter of white
evil that you didn't know existed.
Um,
selling like hotcakes,
I guess hotcakes for pancakes back in
the day. And you know, God damn well,
you know, having pancakes
must have been a fucking tree.
Cause I remember back then when you
read the Tom Sawyer book, right?
Uncle Barry Finn,
it's fucking kids paint a fence just to
get an apple like that was considered
like a treat because all day long you
would just sit around even fucking,
I don't know if she went on shrubs.
I don't know what the fuck you doing.
So anyways, I'm, I want to buy them.
I want to buy something there and uh,
not become the fucking evil person that
boots the people out that are in there.
He just fixed the fucking place
up. It gives a shit, you know,
that's of course the people in
there then fuck the whole place off.
Then I would be upset.
You know how much that plastic,
because it was Jody do
something nice. Um, whatever.
Eventually I'm going to look into that.
Um, so we did with Windsor and uh,
we had a great time and Rosie was there.
So of course I smoked a cigar.
So you know, you know, I only
do two cigars a month now.
So last month I only smoked one.
February I had two and a half because
we started to smoke one and it wasn't
smoking well and we have got halfway
through and I'm like, it's fucking cigar.
Sucks. So actually smoked two and
a half. So I smoked two in January.
I fucked the fucking rain man right now.
So then four and a half, five and a half.
So I'm actually half a cigar
under my goal for this year.
So April 1st used to
already smoked a cigar.
So now I can only have one more or
technically one and a half more.
But I'm actually going to try
and get down to one a month.
And to be honest with you,
I'd Kinda like to go all the way to my
birthday in June and not smoke another
one. Right? Oh goddamn.
And I enjoy them. I enjoy,
I enjoy the fucking lifestyle.
I enjoy the whole fucking thing about it.
I love going in. I love picking
them out. I love the excitement.
I love the smell. I love the old
fucking chairs. You sit there.
I love that there's no fucking
young people there, you
know? And by young people,
I mean anybody 39 and younger,
I used don't run into, you know,
everybody's just chilling the fuck out.
Smoking a cigar.
I don't care what kind
of a maniac you are.
All these fucking kids that they put
on Ritalin and all this type of shit.
You just give these kids a cigar. Sam, sit
down, puff, you know, next thing you know,
you just, you thinking about it,
just think about how great life is.
There's some of us smoke a cigar.
That's how he's,
you start thinking about how
great it is. Great. It is.
He can enjoy the fucking day.
You start planning your retirement.
How the fuck are you going to get out
of this bullshit so you can just sit
around in whatever zen you've
somehow come into. I mean,
I swear to God,
if cigarettes make you feel like that,
I understand why people do that
shit is funny. But you know,
nonsmokers like myself,
you know,
I actually am a smoker now with
the fucking cigars, but, um,
okay.
You know,
he's always looked down on a structure.
People that smoked cigarettes and they
were huddled outside and all that shit.
You know,
I don't know. Maybe the, maybe they,
maybe they know something. I don't,
I'm not advocating smoking. I don't
know what I'm saying. By the way,
Canada, Windsor Airport, Jesus Christ.
What a fucking gem that is.
I love small airports.
There's nothing better than
that little ass fucking airport.
Then when I went to Toronto,
we flew into, we flew over, um,
the propeller plane. Jesus
Christ, if you sub Rosa, you
walk into that. He did. He's,
he's one of those guys. I don't, I
don't want, if he sees propellers,
he feels like he's a riding in
like a model t Ford, you know? Um,
I always just say to myself, I will,
it's, uh, it's going to fly better. Well,
we have much less of a chance because
there's less working parts here.
Perceptive. They go bad, you know, I
don't know. That's what I tell myself.
So anyways, um, we went to Toronto,
we didn't fly into their
nightmare fucking airport.
We flew to the TR Toronto islands,
which I'd never heard of as a fucking
little ass airport there we get picked up
and we took a little fairy,
you know,
it's fucking hilarious
across the western channel.
It literally like,
we started to go and I started videotaping
it and by the time I pay and from out
my side window to the front window,
we had already gotten across to you
get across it in like 30 seconds. Um,
or they have a tunnel, you can walk
underneath the western channel.
We did that on the way back. It
was a nice little ass airport. Um,
after all these years of traveling, I
love a little mom and pop airport. Get in,
get the fuck out. It's
hilarious. She show up.
They still have the old
school metal detectors,
so you don't have to go through that
fucking radiation shower that for some
reason I just don't understand that.
So to stop terrorism,
you're going to give all
your countrymen cancer. Well,
if we fucking kill everybody,
who they going to blow up?
Um, so anyways, how far into
this fucking town? 45 minutes
anyways, but these shows cannot, it
cannot have a bet going any better. And,
um, I've been working my
ass off in Los Angeles, um,
for a reason that I'm not allowed to
say yet for whatever fucking reason.
So I've been worried that I, I
can't, um, you know, I can't fucking,
uh, do stand up as much
as I'd like. But us,
I've been doing a bunch of spots,
like little 10 minute spots trying to say
shap I just do a little bit of my act,
even the jokes, I hate him.
Like Dad, I just fucking say it.
So you remember how it goes. And, um,
I could not be having more
fun up here, Matt. Just having
a fucking great time. Um,
just figuring out my act.
I even figured out this new way to trash
women that like isn't as fucking mean
as I used to do it,
but I still get to make the same points,
so I just don't come off,
you know,
was a complete fucking lunatic all the
time and I don't want to be that guy,
you know what I mean?
As much as you know,
something I'd realized I never finished
reading the me undies think that I,
you know. Okay. Whether you're
wearing a suit or sweats,
you spend almost 24 hours
a day and your underwear,
but instead of making a statement like
Superman's tights under his everyday
clothes, your underwear is probably
boring. [inaudible] about to change that.
Oh yeah. They're, they're about ready
to take your balls to the next level.
They're going to hang a little disco
ball, you know, it's called the third eye,
the third ball right out. If
you fucking nuts, you know,
can you imagine her excited face when
she sees a disco ball hanging off the end
of your Dick? Right. She
probably get that checked. Uh,
please include all of the following.
No Mo Madell is pronounced modal.
Every pair of me undies is made
from sustainable source modal,
modal fabric. That's twice
the softest cotton. Uh,
nothing can describe the fit and feel
of me undies. But once you try them on,
you understand why they're called the
world's most comfortable underwear.
Um, then if you don't love your first
pair of me undies, they're free.
No questions asked me.
And he says dozens of styles and limited
edition prints to help you make a
statement with your underwear.
Whether anyone could see them or not.
Remember Superman.
I don't like that joke.
I remember Superman. What did,
he's fighting Batman. You know,
somebody on Worldstar hip hop,
one of my favorite fucking websites,
you know, watch a people
funny vines, you know,
music that I'd, I'm completely not even
aware of. I get to learn about that shit.
And then, uh, to some of the most fucking
insane fights you're ever going to see.
And there's always a tipping point
when you watch fights on Worldstar.
Is this always the amazement?
And then somewhere it just starts to
become sad. If you just start thinking,
what is wrong with human beings?
Why do we do this shit?
Why can't we just go out to a fucking
McDonald's or a fucking dance club,
you know,
and not have like a 50 on 55 I do have
to tell you the respect I have for
someone that actually would go into one
of those modern day Braveheart fucking
things.
I mean,
I don't give a fuck how many martial
arts classes you've taken in your life.
There is nothing that they teach you in
those fucking classes other than to turn
around and run,
which you already know how to do when
you get in the middle of a fucking Malay
like that. It's just
inevitable. The fucking odds,
you know,
that's the fight version of being like
the helicopter gunner in Vietnam where
they had like a fucking a life expectancy
of two fucking weeks. It's just,
you're just standing there and you
know what's going to happen. All right?
You're going to, you're going to,
something's going to fucking hate you.
You're going to get knocked out and I
have to tell you the influence of MMA on
these fucking street fights.
Now back in the day,
I seem to remember when you
knock somebody out, that was it.
You didn't sit on their chest and throw
another 40 punches to their head waiting
for big John to come over in fucking,
you know,
usher you out of there. There's
no ref. That fucking shit.
We already knocked somebody out.
Then your boot him in the head.
I mean at that point that's like
attempted murder, man, you won.
You're knocked him out.
He'd come up and he'd do this.
You sit on that chest to do
a fucking speed back. They
fucking brutal. But anyways,
you know these me undies,
I'm going to get through this shipping
is free in the u s and Canada and you
save up to $8 a pair with me undies
subscription plan. I get the subscription.
You know,
it's like a fucking end zone dance.
I always thought it was cooler when
you fucking just scored a touchdown.
You flip the ball to the ref and like,
yeah, I'm going to be doing this all day.
If he'd knock somebody out. Yeah.
He just turned around like, yeah,
my job's done here.
You walk away like Clint Eastwood and
one of those drifter movies, you know,
if you sit on that chastity,
like you fucking kind
of spazz out screaming,
what did I tell you bitch?
You know,
with your voice goes up nine octaves
when your voice goes up like nine octaves
like that, you kind of betray your
bad ass. And this he kind of is,
you hear a level of excitement like,
oh my God, I can't believe I won.
That's what I always hear.
Um, having said that,
I wouldn't want to fight
anybody in those videos
and it's not even the fact
that I know I would lose.
I just know that after I was knocked out,
you do irreputable plucking.
I can't even say the word brain damage,
which is unnecessary fucking brain
damage. You're knocked me out. You want,
I'm laying there.
Okay.
My hands are pointing up into outer
space. Um, um, uh, knocked out.
You know why he got to go there
and knock my melon around more. Um,
if I was running for president, I
would bring that up. I see in America,
that goes back to when
you knock somebody out,
you walk away like Clint Eastwood in
a Spaghetti Western. Uh, all right.
Shipping is free and the U s and Canada
and you could save up to $8 a pair with
me. Undies. Subscription plan gets
a subscription or a single pair. Uh,
get 20% off your first order when
you go to [inaudible] dot com slash
[inaudible] that's [inaudible] dot com
slash per for 20% off your first order at
[inaudible] dot com slash bro. All
right. Dollar Shave club, everybody.
He's Christ like a two more
of these fucking things.
Dollar Shave club, everybody.
Dollar Shave club.com as a special
offer for new members who join today,
you'll get a free month of the executive
razor when you buy a tube of Doc Dick
Cavett, ECC, Shave Bada I'm
saying copies. All right,
because that's how I been saying,
even though it's carvers,
I like saying Carvey scan. I'm a big fan
of Dana Carvey. Alright, so there you go.
This is the first time they've
ever done something like this.
And once you try dollar shave club.com
you'll become a proud member like
millions of others.
One reason is because they deliver amazing
razors right to your door for a third
of the price of what the Gri
razor corporations charge.
That means when you
joined dollar Shave Club,
you can afford to shave with a
fresh blade anytime you want,
which feels fantastic.
You'll get a free first class boy,
you get a first class shave when you
use the executive blade without hurting
your wallet. What is
the executive blade? Um,
another reason is that Dr Covey's easy
shave butter using it with the executive
makes the blade glide gently
for the smoothest shave ever.
Dr Carver's shave butter isn't
your average shave cream.
It's a unique conditioning formula
with high quality natural ingredients,
leaving your skin unbelievably
soft and smooth. And right now,
new members who buy a
tube of the shape butter,
get the executive razor for free.
You know what?
They'd never done
anything like this before.
So take advantage of it before they come
to their senses and it's only available
by going to dollar shave club.com/burr
that's dollar shave club.com/bar hey
dollar shave club.com/berm alright.
stamps.com everybody chips to the this
of the last one mercifully. Alright.
stamps.com trips to the post
office are never convenient.
While if you don't like your wife,
they're fucking great.
You know what I'm going to walk,
so why not get postage right from your
desk with stamps.com stamps.com even
gives you special postage discount
she can't get at the post office,
including FirstClass priority mail
express international and more.
You'll never pay full price for postage
again. Here's how stamps.com works.
Using your own computer and printer.
Buy and print official US postage for
any package or letter than just hand your
mail to the mail man or mail
lady or drop it in the mailbox.
It's that easy.
No wonder over 600,000 small businesses
are already using stamps.com.
I use.com whenever I send out one of my
fucking posters. You know it's funny,
I have a poster for this,
this tour,
the plowing ahead tour and it was
an old telly Savalas movie poster.
Right.
And you know,
I spent all this money having this guy
do the whole thing up and we had the
whole fucking tagline on it. You
know, it looks like an action movie.
Like I'm sitting there, but he was
telly Savalas was holding the gun.
I'm holding a microphone. We both
bald baldheaded right. And uh,
he had a casino.
All it should,
I have like a helicopter and all
this dumb shit that I'm fucking into,
so it looks like this action movie.
Then we had the, all this fucking just,
you know, silly shit. Like they tried to
internet porn, they fished out the oceans,
but nothing could stop the
man with no answers. Right.
And then it was like this coming,
you know,
I was supposed to be
like this movie poster.
So I don't think the
casinos understood it.
They took away all of the, uh, the,
the words, whatever the fuck
you call it, all the texts,
they took all of it away and they just
have this standalone poster and now I
just look like a magician.
Like is he going to come in in a
helicopter and make a truck disappear?
Like it doesn't make any sense.
And I spent all this fucking money on
it and most of them are just using my
poster for my last tour,
you know,
when I had with what's left of
my hair grown out in a beard.
So I don't even look the same. It's
just, it's been a shit show. Anyways.
Right now sign up for
stamps.com and use my last name,
birth for this special offer,
a four week trial plus $110 bonus that
includes postage and a digital scale.
A Call to action verbatim.
Read this verbatim.
A don't wait, get started.
Uh, with stamps.com today.
Go to stamps.com before
you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in [inaudible] that
stamps.com enter bur bur there you go.
Was that verbatim enough?
I'm such a control freak.
I can't even handle people who've given
me money telling me what the fuck they
do. Um, 55 minutes. All right.
This whole day's getting away from you
haven't even read any of the fucking
questions and I haven't even talked about
the Bruins. How we're one point out.
We beat St Louis and
then we lost to Chicago.
Um, I of course didn't see any games
because I was fucking traveling.
Um, you know, it's funny,
I had like five or six country
Chicago fence talking shit. You know,
it's so funny. Last time we played them,
we beat them. I don't talk any shit.
Do I talk and he should know, right?
Hate these fucking people like these,
these whack a mole fans that you know,
oh we could you rose today.
Then they ducked back down. They'll
know where to be found. You know,
when you fucking loose like Chicago's
gun to do in the playoffs, you fucking
God damn.
Cons.
I actually liked the Black Hawks and
fans like that make me fucking rude.
Root against them. So anyways,
um, coming up this week,
my Bruins, my beloved Bruins.
All right, we are playing.
Our next game is uh,
uh,
where the fuck is that? I think we're
playing into, no, he played Carolina,
I believe.
I think we played Carolina next street.
I get the schedule right here.
Where is the schedule? All right.
We play Carolina on Tuesday.
It's at the TD bank,
north fucking Home Depot Garden.
Whatever the fuck they call
it. The Carolina in a tourist
sleep plays this tough.
They always match up. Well, there's always
a tough game. And then we have Detroit,
which is huge. They're one point
against the ahead of us on Thursday.
And then our last game is against
Ottawa on Saturday. All right.
So basically the two teams
in front of us are, uh,
Detroit and Philly both one
point ahead of us, I believe.
So the great thing is during this week,
Detroit and Philly play each other.
So no,
I think Philly's a few points that had,
so I'm just fulfilling to just when
the rest of the way out. All right.
I, at this point, I have
to root against Detroit.
I don't have anything against Detroit
other than their fucking country fans.
And they really are cunty fence.
You know what I mean?
The funny thing about them is they don't
realize that they're run is over and
that it's now all about Chicago and
La and they're wearing the crown.
You know what I mean?
For some reason Detroit is still
living off fucking Eisenman, you know?
I guess they won one last decade to
pot. Oh, actually they went to, yeah,
but you can just see, you can see
it in Detroit. It's over. You know?
It's something that I'm
going to experience with
Brady and Belichick are gone
and I'm going to be like, yeah, but
we're the patriots. It's like, yeah,
but that God, yeah, yeah.
They're wearing the same uniform,
but it's not the same. I'm fucking
with the, I actually love Detroit.
I love the franchise. I don't
like the fence. Um, you know,
and I've never been that way as I like
to think with all the success that I only
talk shit if people giving me shit.
That's how I try to be, you know,
I don't try to act like,
because my teams are successful.
That means somehow in my own
personal life, I'm a success.
Like some people do those.
You know what?
I'm really judging all black hawks and
red Redwing fence by half a dozen people,
which isn't fair. So, you know what,
good luck to all of you. And uh,
I hope to Bruins fucking pull it out.
And if we don't,
we got no one to blame but
ourselves just fucking good Lord.
What a fucking season up, down,
up, down, up, down, up, down.
That's what the fuck it's been.
Now I just need up for the last
two or three up just fucking nice.
Three game winning streak and no
one will remember any of this shit.
Dan Shaughnessy is sitting there
with the fucking hard on being like,
I can finally write an article
about hockey that I understand
somebody blew it. Oh yeah. I could
write this all fucking day. All right,
let's get to the questions then. I got to
get the fuck Outta here. All right. Um,
the all star Cafe, uh,
on March 28 podcasts,
you briefly mentioned you were regular
muncher and Nia was a waitress.
The all state, not the all star. Uh,
for some reason he wrote all star up
here then all state before she got pink
slipped and now and now and the now closed
down Allstate cafe and the upper west
side.
I thought your listeners
might be intrigued to learn
that your meeting place was
also a meeting place for a young teacher
and her murderer in January of 1973
during a one night stand,
murdering a partner guarantees there ain't
no second night, right. Jesus Christ.
I didn't know that the grotesque multi
stabbing crime got so much infamous
publicity that the pub changed his name
from the Wm tweets to the Allstate.
The murderer inspired the
book and subsequent movies
starring the then scantily
clad Diane Keaton also.
Apparently Kevin Bacon had
ones tended bar there too.
I wonder if they fired him also.
I didn't know that.
Jesus, that's fucking creepy. I don't
believe in ghosts or anything like that.
Not even remotely, but that type
of shit is just scary by the way.
I love hearing about history even as
much as I fucking that cake walk thing.
I was trashing that guy. I like
that type of shit. Um, all right,
girlfriend bothered and annoyed
by sexy TV show character.
Uh,
dear Billy blank balls.
My girlfriend and I were recently watching
the new season of daredevil and we're
enjoying it.
However,
one character electra
was introduced and uh,
she bothered the hell out of
my girlfriend for reference.
Electra is this character that is sexy,
provocative,
and an all around Badass Ninja woman.
Electra is also like a
weird sort of, isn't that that
mythology thing? What is the,
what is that weird fucking
thing isn't sit down with,
I'm not even going say
it because if I'm wrong,
it has to do with some sort of creepy
sexual relations within the family,
doesn't it? You know, daughter,
father and then the other one,
his son,
mother with a son kills
the dad or some shit.
It's just fucking weird when I see
those types of stories actually start
believing in Adam and eve.
Yeah,
there was just two people and they
bagged and then they had this obsessed.
She was fucking horseshit for a couple
of generations until we fucked ourselves
up. Maybe that did up and maybe that's
why neanderthals and all like or whatever
they are, the original cavemen, their
heads are all fucked up. Look, and
it's because everyone was related.
Um, and who the fuck knows anyways,
she was a cool character,
but my girlfriend hated her.
I noticed that it wasn't anything against
the character since she couldn't tell
me why she didn't like her
other than she just bothers her.
Other people have told me that their
girlfriends slash wives are the same way
with electro when watching this
show with their significant other.
I know it isn't just this character
because any female that is in a sexy,
Badass role,
I've noticed women specifically,
ones with both boyfriends don't like,
uh,
is this just some kind
of insecurity women have?
Do they really dislike their boyfriends?
Seeing someone that may be
sexier than them? Um, well yeah,
if you fucking put it that way, they're
going to be annoyed. Okay honey, you know,
I see that girl.
Look how much sexier she is.
Then when she watched his fight club,
you know,
does she say how much fucking much
better. Well, Brad Pitt's looking anyways.
Are they worried that this fictional TV
characters going to steal me away from
her? I am wondering if I should
say anything because quite frankly,
it's starting to get on my nerves.
She will root against the character for
no reasons besides the ones listed above.
Um, I don't know if I
would just make her move,
make her more pissed off though. Have
you ever been in a situation like this?
Love the show and as always, go
fuck yourself. Here's the thing,
one of the worst things you can do when
you get into a relationship with a woman
is to start having your behavior be
dictated by just trying to keep them in a
good mood. All right? I'm not saying
walk around and be an Asshole,
but if you're not being a fucking
asshole and they're just being moody,
fucking assholes, like you got to
call him out on it. Yeah. Like,
and,
and this is another thing too,
you got to treat them like adults
rather than treating them like children,
which is what a lot of guys do because
physically was stronger than them.
So you feel like if you
say anything to them,
it's like you're yelling at a child.
You're not.
Not only is that an adult and a lot of
ways they're more advanced because they
can't beat the fuck out of you.
They have to go,
they have to go with their mental,
right.
That's why they can just manipulate
you like a fucking little puppet there
because they can just play Jedi
mind games because they, they,
they're not going to, they from
day one, they're like, all right,
this fucking thing is going to be
stronger than me at some point.
So I need to learn how to control
it. Just using my brain. Right.
That's how you end.
End Up holding fucking yard goes can
hook no woman's cells anymore. Right.
They barely even cook.
So I end up at fucking brunch.
This is what you've got to say.
Um,
you just kind of just hit pause and just,
I would just be like,
what is your problem with this character?
You're ruining the show for me. Okay.
If look at, look at
daredevil. He's got abs.
You see me acting like a fucking
baby about this. You know,
you don't like the way you look.
Go to the gym at the one she'd be
inspired by this fuck there. That's,
that's what I feel when I, when I watch
a superhero movie other I the other,
other than like a, when the fuck is
his dumb horse, shit. Gonna be over.
It always makes me feel like,
yeah, I got to hit the gym.
I could literally sit there and watch
Thor who's probably a foot taller than me,
a thousand times better looking
than I'm ever going to be.
And all that dude does is make me
want to go to the gym. But then again,
if you look at our roles,
like all I need to do is earn enough money
where I can get a Ferrari in a toupee
and next thing you know,
I can bank some whore that's
spinning a fucking magazine.
And that's basically how it works.
If I drive the car in the
right part of the world, right?
Drive around the fucking
French Riviera at Jesus Christ,
you have no idea what you're going to
be banging. They don't have that option.
You know what I mean? They can't be
like, well, I'm a six, but you know,
if I start making money I can go
get myself a Brad Pitt. You can't,
Eh, you know what? You
can't blame society.
You got to blame the
good Lord for that one.
So maybe that's why.
Maybe that's why,
cause no matter what she does, she can. I
don't know. I don't fucking know. Ask Her,
but you know something I wouldn't be
on, you know, she's ruined in your show.
You got to call her out on
it. Um, all right. Okay.
Going bald. Dear Billy bald
cap. I'm 24 and I'm going bald.
This runs in my family is both my
grandfathers were bald so I don't have any
sort of identity crisis about it and in
fact I'm leaning into it and we'll joke
about it when appropriate. My question to
you is, when do I finally start buzzing,
buzzing everything away?
The last thing I want to do
is rocket George [inaudible]
kid cause stands a look.
But we'd like to have a full head of hair
while I can before I look like I'm in
denial.
No comb overs for this cut.
My hair is thin but still
covers everything on top though.
My Barbara did crack more jokes than
usual at my last, at my expense.
Last time I went to get a cut.
No,
I didn't provide a picture because
this isn't a fucking roguey commercial.
Given your experience.
I love to hear your input on what,
when you pulled the
trigger to buzzard all,
all the way and possibly
the input of the lovely Nia.
What? Jesus Christ. What am I?
You're fucking stylist. Well,
I think you know something.
If your barber starts making jokes,
you know what I mean?
I feel like there's not enough time left
on the clock for you to make a comeback.
That's basically like now you line it
up and the dude across to you is talking
shit about how they're moving on to the
next round of the playoffs and you're
not.
So it sounds like it's already over,
you know?
I don't know, Dude, why? What am I,
what kind of a fucking man asks another
man a question like this? Just fucking,
you know,
shave your fucking head or go get
a hair plugs or put Rogaine on it,
or raw diet at different fucking cover.
I'll give a fuck what you do with it.
What is my experience? My experience
was when I was just sick of it,
I was sick of the slow and I
was just like, you know what?
Let's just put this
thing out of its misery.
MMM.
And I gotta tell you, it's not nearly
as bad as everybody fucking thanks.
Who's kidding? Who? Everybody would
love to have a full head of hair,
but you know something.
I gotta be honest with you.
Once you start buzzing your head,
it's kind of fucking awesome.
You know what is great about having a
shaved head? You're always ready to go.
I got to tell you, as much as I would
love to still have a full head of hair,
I love the fact that
I'm always ready to go.
All I gotta do is throw a shirt on,
splash a little water on my face,
and you have no fucking idea that I was
laying in my sweatpants five minutes
earlier. Oh. Speaking of which, I'm just
kidding. I always make sure I get ready,
you know?
Okay.
There was this fucking person,
you know, I went out, you know,
I took some pictures with
people after the show and uh,
yeah,
these fucking people that have like,
this fucking guy comes up,
I can already smell them.
All right?
And then he goes to put his arm around
me during the fucking picture and I'm
telling you like literally could make
paneer peel off the fucking walls was how
bad this guy's body odor was.
And he's with other people and
they don't smell. It's like,
why don't you say something to them?
Because I'm not going to say it.
Okay,
you paid money to see me,
right?
I gave you a show and then I come out
there and take a picture and then I tell
you, you smell bad. I wouldn't do that
to somebody, but Jesus fucking Christ.
He was fucking hilarious about this
person too. I kept running into him.
Okay.
And then this person just loved to tell
a story that somehow involved, you know,
lifting his arms up past his
fucking shoulders. Jesus. Fuck man.
I never noticed how much you lift your
arms during telling a story until I ran
into this,
this guy fucking reeked fucking rate,
just completely fucking unacceptable.
Well into his fucking
twenties and he's standing,
he's got a couple of friends
with them who don't reek.
Okay?
Oh my God. You know, wish I bad. I wish
I had one of those old school fucking,
you know, the spray on deodorant.
And as he was telling this story,
I'd be like yeah,
and just holding my nose and I would
just spray under one arm pit. No,
keeps telling this story,
this spraying under the other one.
And then I just hand them the
can't do the math there. Fuck. Oh,
alright.
Psycho girlfriend.
Um, all right. Okay.
Psycho girlfriend. Uh, where am I? Okay.
So my girlfriend and I had been together
for about five years and lately I've
been feeling the get engaged
pressure from her family. Well, yeah,
I'm 23 and she's 21. All right,
let me rephrase that. Well, now,
um, I thought you guys were older. Uh,
we've been together since high school
and I haven't experienced much else
besides, of course, the young
middle school, tug job girlfriends,
I'm afraid of Sunday regretting missing
out on meeting a ton of different girls.
Like all my buddies have been, I
mean, you're only young once, right?
My girlfriend flips out on me about
watching porn because I'm thinking about
other girls and she acts like I'm cheating
on her and half the time when we're
out she thinks I'm checking out other
girls. Cause you probably are dude,
because you want to cause you
want to break up with her.
That's what I'm guessing.
She's a drop dead gorgeous girl so I
don't get what she's so insecure about.
But like I said,
she's crazy.
She gets abusive with me and I just kind
of sit there and take it all the time.
Um, she's Latina by the way.
Honduran and Nicaraguan.
She's got that wild temper. Um, all right.
I was that considered racist to say that
Latina chicks are a little crazier than,
than what? Unlike what pasty
drunken Irish chicks. Oh yeah.
They're always so even killed
what I asked for space.
I woke up the next day
and my car was keyed.
Okay.
She claims she had nothing to do with it.
I love the girl.
She's all I've ever known and
she's amazing most of the time.
But I'm not sure if I can live like this
forever with their temporary jealousy.
What would you do anyways?
Love the podcast.
Thanks for the advice and go fuck
yourself. P s good luck with the home gym.
Everybody knows.
Yeah,
you got no business in irregularly.
I'll go fuck yourself.
I can not put us in a regular
gym. Oh, when you do what?
You're sitting here and you're a
fucking God. Damn. You know something?
I actually had fucking,
yeah,
I actually had sympathy for it.
I was going to give you some good advice.
You know what? Go Fuck Yourself. You
know what your problem is in this thing.
You know, you, you're just,
it allowed it. You're young.
I'm not going to be a dick to you. Okay?
Cause you're young. This is the deal.
All right? You got yourself
a hot girl. All right.
And you did not have set
up the relationship. She
fucking rolled all over yet.
You're asking what I do in your situation.
If I was 23,
I'd be doing what you were doing.
I'd be staying in the relationship,
wanting to get out, um, and
dealing with this bullshit.
But I can tell you this right now.
Her looks aren't always going to be there,
but she's always going to have keys.
You know what I mean?
So that's what you're signing up for.
The looks go out the fucking window.
You're marrying the fucking person
that this fucking lunatic. Every time,
you know, if, God forbid,
your mailman is a fucking woman who's
younger than her at that point, you know,
I th I don't know. I don't know.
I can do it was too wishy washy.
I can't tell whether you
fucking want to be in it or not,
but I can tell you this right
now. Um, any woman keys your car,
that's it. It's fucking
over. Okay. That is a,
the level of being a
complete fucking psycho.
A complete disrespect for
your own property and assign
that when she was a child,
she was never told no. The fact that you
would go out and do something like that.
Yeah,
I dunno.
It sounds to me like you want to go
fucking get some notches on your belt and
you're afraid that if you do and you break
up with this girl that she's going to
fucking stab you.
Um,
yeah,
I dunno. I got claustrophobic
reading it if that means anything,
but I'm a fucking lunatic.
Right? Sketchy ex-girlfriend.
Hey you cunty Leprechaun.
Jason.
Everybody's staring into
the red hat shit this week.
Every once in a while I got
to give you guys shit to get.
Can you be a little more original?
I liked that Billy blank ball.
That was fucking funny.
58 fucking, you know,
fucking red head shops in a
row, but I get it. You know,
I get it. You don't have an hour's
time. You can do a 10 minutes.
Set your a showcase comic. Um, all
right. Hey, you cut g leprechaun.
I am 16 years old and my girlfriend
is 15 today. She texted me,
she texted me with a picture of
a tattoo asking if I like it.
It is what it is. The date of her
grandfather's death. Personally,
I hate tattoos and thanks.
If she keeps getting them,
she will look like a fucking phone book.
I also think her mother is irresponsible,
spelled with a bunch of ease.
He responsible for letting her
get a tattoo spelled with one ho.
So young. What are your thoughts
about this and how, how,
uh,
what's your thoughts about this and how
she didn't tell me till after she got it.
Thank you. I love your
shows and your podcast. Um,
yeah.
All right.
She's 15 she already got her first tattoo,
which you got to do is close your eyes
and age or when is she getting the face
tattoo and the nose ring and the fucking
Olympic fucking rings in our ears to be
different. Um, yeah, I,
I'm not into tattoos.
You know, I think a certain
type of person can pull it off.
Um,
and that's not 98% of the population,
but 98% of the population for some
reason has tattoos. Now I don't get it.
I feel like there's a certain level
bad ass dude in a certain level,
bad ass chick that gets tattoos.
And when you meet him it makes
sense in it actually, you know,
I dunno if I see a woman and she's
a bad ass and she has tattoos,
it actually makes them more attractive
to me if she's just some fucking dope,
you know?
And she has like some advice
column tattooed on the
back of her fucking neck or
some Chinese sign above her ass
crack, you know, symbol then yeah,
it's just like Jesus Christ.
You know,
like the amount of people
out there that sleeves
like back in the day
when you got a sleeve,
I mean you were like some biker outlaw,
you know.
Now it's like you work at urban
outfitters, you know the biggest,
baddest thing about you is your fucking
music selection on your fucking iPhone.
I have no idea. All I know is I got to get
a rental car in 10 minutes. If I don't,
I'm going to be late to my show.
So this is the podcast for this week,
the Monday morning podcast.
God bless all of you.
I love when you guys trashed me in
the fucking emails, but yeah. Can we,
can we just keep, can you keep it
interesting for the reader here?
I know I'm a red head. I know
the reason he jokes, but come on.
What if I did that with my standup act?
Get Out,
which had come out and see
me if I was out there. Go on.
Watch to deal with New
Yorker. No. Um, all right.
Go Fuck Yourself.
I'll check in on you on Thursday.